oui
c'est un intime de françois hollande que
nous recevons cette semaine à preuve par
3 bernard poignant bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être là conseillé un peu
spéciale on peut le dire tout de suite
vous avez un bureau à l'élysée bien sûr
vous avez l'oreille du chef de l'état
mais vous n'apparaissez pas dans
l'organigramme de l'elysée et vous aurez
l'occasion d'expliquer votre rôle exact
tout à l'heure à perrine tarneaud et
vous répondrais également aux questions
de karine perret de l' agence
france-presse
bien sûr cette semaine comme toutes les
semaines notre partenaire pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat notre
partenaire avec également dailymotion
c'est la première fois dans un poignant
que françois hollande se voit créditer
d'un sans faute depuis son élection la
gestion des tragédies qui ont endeuillé
la france est réveillé les peurs a été
saluée par tous un par la droite par la
gauche les sondages s'envole avec un
bond de plus de 20 points 10 l'un est il
enfin devenu président par l'épreuve
je pense pour moi il l'est depuis le
début mais les événements ont révélé sa
personnalité je pense davantage aux
français dès le mercredi
pas simplement dimanche dès le mercredi
quand ils essaieront du tout de suite
sur les lieux montrant son empathie et
sa compassion et en même temps le soir
même en s'adressant aux français
donc tant la même journée il était le
holland que je connais dans l'empathie
proche des proches de la douleur et
l'intimité donc ça ce sont des traits de
caractère et le soir l'attend aussi sur
des lots l'attendait sur des décisions
si elles sont venues mais le soir s'il
est dans la gravité et souvenez-vous du
taux d'audience il a été écoutée par
près de 22 millions de téléspectateurs
alors que quelques jours auparavant ses
voeux ne l'avait été que par moins de 10
c'est à dire que tout d'un coup les
français se sont tournés vers lui parce
que il incarne la france dont la durée
d'un quinquennat et il attendait de lui
et des décisions et la conduite
malheureusement d'une opération pour à
la suite de cet acte barbare donc il
s'est révélé la aux yeux des français
ou plutôt les français on se sont
tournés vers lui puisque bilingue sur la
fonction régalienne suprême exactement
que vous soyez populaire ou impopulaires
et que la politique que vous menez soit
jugée bonne ou pas bonne
dans ces moments-là il est l'incarnation
même de la nation de la france et de la
république en ce qui nous concerne il a
eu des mérites particulier quand même
non ada ensuite mercredi jeudi vendredi
samedi dimanche
mais dès mercredi je pense qu'il a posés
là le les actes qu'il fallait est-ce que
vous même vous avez changé votre regard
sur françois hollande non non non non
parce que je sais que c'est quelqu'un
qui est capable d'un extrême sang froid
en même temps d'une extrême compassion
qui s'est décidé dans les moments graves
comme celui là qui peut prendre dans
d'autres moments son temps pour des 6 et
ce n'est pas brutal dans la vie
politique intérieure
il n'a pas à décider forcément
rapidement et brutalement sur tout sujet
donc parfois on dit de lui qu'il est
hésitant qui sinon je n'ai jamais
regardé comme ça il n'est pas brutal
il n'est pas brutal donc il peut prendre
du temps écouter et ensuite décider mais
là dans les moments graves et autant que
je sais c'est le trancher des classes là
je n'appartiens pas bien sûr au aux
réunions de crise ou encore moins bien
sûr au conseil de défense et parfois
vous on vous le voyez vous le voyez
entre soi je ris quand je les ai sentis
extrêmement concentré tendu et tranchant
donc à vous écouter j'ai ce n'est que
justice donc ils bénéficient aujourd'hui
de deux estime et de respect ben j'ai
trouvé d'abord que pendant deux ans il a
été très souvent massacrés par les uns
et par les autres donc le le fameux
hollande machine et en s'en est donné à
coeur joie et
ça m'a forcément marqué les français
mais ça nous attriste est les uns et les
autres bien sûr qui le connaissons et
qui ont une proximité plus ou moins
grande
avec lui j'ai même été affectés ont dit
qu'ils aient exercé enfin clic il sait
où se montrent indifférents
alors c'est en même temps pour le voir
et le connaître depuis longtemps c'est
quelqu'un qui ne se plaint jamais qui
n'a pas de peur physique qui est très
courageux très robuste et qui est
capable de faire face à mon avis à
toutes les situations et qu'on produit
donc pendant deux ans le holland bashing
où il a fait face et je pense non moi je
n'ai jamais entendu se plaindre tout cas
auprès de moi j'ai toujours vu régulier
continuant sa tâche mais je me suis
toujours dit bon sang qu'est-ce qu'il en
prend dans la figure
le pouvoir de l'indifférence alors comme
disait françois mitterrand mitterrand
avait mis le sait ça puisque nous en
avons parlé mais il se souvient bien de
cet entretien
elkabbach qui a été diffusée après sa
mort selon l'accord qu'il avait avec
jean pierre elkabbach et c'est le
dernier mot quand el kabbaj lui demande
quelle est la qualité suprême pour
exercer cette fonction
terrible réponse de françois mitterrand
il dit après deux secondes de silence
l'indifférence alors c'est pas une
réponse qui me convient je sais pas s'il
convient françois hollande
mais quand on est dans la fonction
présidentielle où il faut faire du cuir
mais la différence aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui à non il est pas et à noël
et l'est pas il a même été je le mets le
mercredi soir de l'attentât jean-pierre
jouyet a réuni les commandes du cabinet
présent et pour nous parler un peu de la
journée de la suite et il nous a dit que
le président était très affecté mais
toucher de soirée vous avez des en même
temps il a fait face je vais utiliser ou
même de l'expression de hollande bashing
quake sa fille nina de alors
luc mélenchon arnaud montebourg en
passant par nicolas sarkozy dans tous
les cas selon les propos qui lui avaient
jeu je sais pas si c'est fini en tout
cas points critiques ne sont pas réduits
au silence est contenue dans la
personnalité non non ça il ya des choses
qui reviennent mais pour moi il ya trois
procès qui devrait cesser 3,3 procès
pour le procès en légitimité de la
gauche a dirigé la france parce qu'il a
été fait quand même puisque ce pas
madame nathalie kosciusko morizet je me
souviens disant que la gauche a gagné
par effraction donc elle a gagné par
l'élection
ce qui n'est pas pareil et puis le
procès en capacité de françois hollande
a présidé la france ce procès lui a été
fait sans arrêt et compris par son
prédécesseur main pour essayer de
s'appeller les bases de sa personnalité
et même le procès en légèreté
gouvernementales et en amateurisme
souvenez vous ça a été fait à de
nombreuses reprises et je pense que
c'est trois procès là en légitimité pour
la gauche en capacité pour le président
et on légèreté pour le gouvernement
elles sont à remiser au au magasin des
souvenirs à vianne ajoutera d'autres
encore des procès alors peut-être
qu'alors on peut en parler
et bien écoutez l'absence de résultats
économiques à la france est en cale
sèche
tout au long de l'année 2015 mois après
mois on va encore voir le chômage s'est
aggravé
alors j'espère que non ça ne se grandit
l'année c'est ce que disent y coller
mais j'espère qu'ils seront des
prévisions avec le 104 1000 chômeurs de
plus tu en métropole 10 l'unedic c'est
ce qu'ils disent c'est exactement alors
les les événements qui se sont passés ne
vont pas amené le président à mon avis
je peux être démentie a changé son cap
économique parce qu'il croit beaucoup à
la politique qu'il a qui l'a engagé avec
les 50 milliards de réduction de
dépenses publiques et les 40 milliards
d' aides aux entreprises
mais vous le rend plus fort et plus
ferme ce sont ses mots d'ailleurs je
crois il dit qu'ils seront plus fort et
plusieurs caisses que ça le rend
aujourd'hui parce qu'il vous dit de vos
échanges plus fort plus ferme pour
imposer ce cap et s'est vu je pense que
oui je pense qu'il est
saleh je peux faire de transposition ce
qui s'est passé dans la semaine de 7 et
8 9 janvier et la politique est
néanmoins au sial je pense que la
personnalité lui même est forcément
conforté alors il va continuer sur son
axe il va pas en changer les lois qui
sont en cours vont être votés débattu
d'abord puis voté puis promulgué le cap
économique a été fixée il faut
simplement que ça donne quelques
résultats elle effectue vous avez raison
m
le vrai résultat aux yeux des français
sera mesuré quand le nombre des chômeurs
de la catégorie à c'est à dire ceux qui
sont l'expression n'est peut-être pas
bonne pleinement au chômage quand c'est
là commencera à diminuer alors j'espère
qu'on le verra je peux pas pronostiqueur
bien sûr dans l'année 2015 et à ce
moment là et à mon avis d'ailleurs si ça
commence à baisser à décroître
les français ne le croiront pas tout de
suite ils auront des doutes
donc il faut plusieurs mois et françois
hollande se l'imaginent un considère que
c'est possible à partir de l'année 2000
d'accord on le dit d'ailleurs peut-être
dans le deuxième semestre
et puis voyez pour connaître pour avoir
l'oeuvre entendu de quelques industriels
qui m'ont dit au moins un grand groupe
que ce qui s'est passé là fait regarder
la france dans le monde différemment
leur donne pas des marchés des contrats
et facilite quand même parce que il y a
eu certains hollande machine mais il ya
eu aussi une france machine et ça
c'était très mauvais sur sur toute la
planète
et quelque part le monde a retrouvé sa
france alors j'ai parlé des sondages
tout à l'heure vous est surveillée de
très près bien sûr l elysée il ya il ya
des bonds spectaculaires d'ombessa ses
produits sous d'autres présidences
tellement tragique pour faire vibrer ça
s'est produit pour lui en janvier
marguerite rang mais la suite n'a pas
été bonne prépare donc venir attention
j'ai envie de dire attention attention
à la grande illusion alors je fais une
comparaison parce que j'ai vécu l'autre
période
françois mitterrand après ces sondages
très florissant change michel rocard et
s'est pas compris sa part les français
en même temps très peu de mois après le
parti socialiste est engluée dans les
affaires refaire l'histoire mais on est
que tous ariane référence ses rebonds
sont fragiles tragique des guerres oui
les attentats mais je pense que ça
diminuera pas ça ne reviendra pas de
reviendra pas comme avant donc pour dire
non à je ne suis pas je suis pas
prophète c'est pas un prophète c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est un souhait que
j'ai bien sûr vous allez quand même vous
interroger sur 2017
bernard poignant est ce que vous pensez
que après ce qui s'est passé parce que
vous dites ça ne reviendra pas comme
avant l'image du chef de l'état est ce
que certains pourraient encore
aujourd'hui et demain envisager une
autre candidature socialiste en 2017
voire la nécessité pour françois
hollande de passer par une primaire
alors pour moi la primaire je l'espère
en tout cas et aux socialistes qui pense
je le redis enterrés là si le président
sortant
celui qui décidera c'est pas moi mais si
ces juges jeudi quand même mon souhait
s'il est si les candidats au
renouvellement de son mandat il faut
s'en tenir là d'accord selon l'adage de
raffarin que j'aime bien
il n'y a pas de concurrent dans le camp
du président donc s'il est candidat
c'est lui qui va le décider
je crois qu'il faut s'en tenir là je
vois mal le président de la république
en fonction
soumis à des primaires donc un double
élection ait le risque en plus d'un
dérapage de primaire ou d'un score moyen
au médium non le président sortant s'il
est candidat
eh bien il faut tous derrière lui ça va
être un paradoxe pour le parti
socialiste parce qu'en 2011 on a fait
des primaires qui ne sont pas dans nos
statuts et on n'en ferait pas alors
qu'elles sont dans nos statuts mais je
crois qu'il faut avoir une capacité
d'adaptation à la situation a bien voilà
la réponse en tous les cas le sénat
c'est vous qui vous exprimer
voyant ce soir votre réponse en tous les
cas à thierry mandon le ministre du
gouvernement qui avait dit qu'il fallait
absolument passer par une primaire il
l'a dit à votre place il ya quelques
semaines une question je pense qu'il a
changé d'avis il a changé d'avis et je
pense c'est un homme intelligent donc il
a fallu changer d'avis un mot sur les
autres responsables politiques et
notamment marine le pen comme est-ce que
vous avez jugé son attitude ces
dernières semaines et pensez vous comme
le président du sénat gérard larcher
qu'elle a peut-être perdu la chance de
se qualifier pour le second tour de la
prochaine présidentielle havre je pense
que j'ai entendu jara larcher de dire ça
faut être très prudent sur les résultats
d'une élection
je pense que malgré la polémique du
samedi
je crois que sont sa place auraient été
au milieu de tous les français elle a
sans doute raté quelque chose
le président comme le premier ministre
ont dit comme le premier secrétaire du
parti socialiste vient qui veut bien
qu'il veut et donc pour 2010 est un pays
peut-être
attendez on verra les élections verra
envers envers l'accord précité jean
pierre raffarin il est à votre place la
semaine dernière il estimé que le trésor
de l'union nationale était dans les
mains de françois hollande et que
c'était à lui d'agir il est conscient de
cela le chef de l'état oui mais qu'est
ce qu'on entend par union nationale
s'est passé c'est pas un gouvernement
rassemblant tous les partis je pense
qu'aujourd'hui c'est plus un état
d'esprit qu'il faut garder l'assemblée
nationale ne change pas de configuration
les débats économiques sociaux sociétaux
fiscaux énergétique
ils reprennent leur l'endroit après tout
quand on quand on sort de là redevenir
comme avant
oh je pense moi j'espère en tout cas que
l'état d'esprit chagrin dire que la
hiérarchie des apportant ses des
urgences soit plus relativiser alors on
va voir si c'est l'état d'esprit du côté
du parti socialiste où on sait que le
cap que vous avez réaffirmer le cap de
françois hollande est contestée par
certains et frondeur karine perret de l'
agence france-presse
va nous rejoindre dans un instant mais
voyons d'abord sur ce thème
le reportage de marie brémaud
existe-t-il un devoir de silence une
obligation à l'accalmie au vu des
événements 13
des semaines passées pour ceux au sein
de la majorité qui n'ont jamais ménagé
le président de la république et
l'exécutif pas question de se coucher
ce qui est important c'est d'abord que
le terrorisme ne change pas les
habitudes démocratique de ce pays
on n'est pas dans un état de siège etc
il faut que la vie quand des
représentants république l'a dit
reprenne ses droits et on recommence
comme avant
l'expression sera peut-être atténuer
l'expression des différences mais le
débat de fond reste et à gauche de la
gauche la cible de toutes les attaques
c'est la future loi macro puisqu'on sait
dire que la loi magron représente un
certain nombre de régression sociale et
c'est pas parce qu'il ya eu un événement
d'une telle ampleur que je me priverais
de dire oui mais pour d'autres et la
donne avait les bien changé et certains
frondeurs pourrait faire preuve de plus
de retenue dans leur opposition au
gouvernement s'il y a deux semaines à
une soixantaine de députés auraient pu
voter contre le projet de loi macron il
ne serait plus qu'une trentaine
aujourd'hui un effet collatéral de
l'après 11 janvier sur lequel compte
matignon mais les irréductibles le poil
à gratter la république ne sont pas
prêts à se laisser bâillonner
moi j'espère que ceux qui sont contre
parce qu'ils ont vraiment des arguments
et plus le centre votes contre et que
ceux qui sont pour parce qu'on leur a
dit qu'il fallait voter pour appeler
réfléchisse à deux fois
ça fera pas une majorité ça c'est sûr on
dit souvent il faut que nous soyons
solidaires de l'exécutif c'est vrai mais
c'est bien aussi quand l'exécutif est
solidaire de sa majorité et de son
électorat
réponse le 26 janvier avec le début de
l'examen de la loi macron où l'on verra
si la politique reprend le dessus n'a
jamais participé à une émission
politique
celle-ci vanger aussi une ambiance oui
on n'entend pas une question oui donc
vous venez dire j'espère que l'état
d'esprit va changer est ce que vous
pensez que ça peut perdurer dans le
domaine politique
je l'espère en tout cas j'écoutais votre
reportage avant de parler d'union
nationale il faut parler d'union
socialiste voyez vous c'est déjà pas mal
ça entendu aujourd'hui les frondeurs
dire que la loi macron à l'état n'était
pas votable donc la politique reprend
ses droits un petit à petit oui
forcément
mais moi je souhaite qu'ils
réfléchissent à leur vote final ce que
dans la loi il ya beaucoup de choses
hein il ya 106 article de mémoire il ya
plein de sujets abordés donc on peut
être hostile ou en désaccord ou en
moitié en accord avec telle ou telle
disposition donc ça s'avère le débat
parlementaire
après il ya le vote final donc j'espère
que pour le vote final l'ensemble du
groupe socialistes et au delà se
retrouvent juge l'union socialiste est
tout le monde un seul vote alors en
national le vote final
je veux bien le vote final c'est pas la
réalité ah bon on verra on verra
ça va cheminer ça va cheminer savent
aussi qu'ils seront moins nombreux à
voter montre par rapport à seulement je
le sens je le souhaite oui parce que
c'est une loi où il ya qui traite
beaucoup de sujets donc à partir de ce
moment là vous pouvez être réservé voire
hostiles avec quel sujet et on prendre
prétexte pour voter pour la contre la
loi toute entière c'est ça d'une
difficulté
c'est une loi ça touche un mille sujets
enfin j'veux pas 1000 mètres des
dizaines de sujets donc j'espère que les
socialistes qui sont pas d'accord ou
réservés sur tel ou tel sujet mais qui
peuvent l'être sur beaucoup d'autres et
bien dans le vol final qui sera quelque
part un vote qui est d'accord avec
l'ensemble du gouvernement se retrouve
même si dans le débat parlementaire vous
avez plus de nuances après tout il ya
des amendements il ya ceux ci à cela si
vous pouvez les amendements qui passe
d'autres qui passent pas mais en finale
jeu lorsque la première lecture sera
terminée je souhaite vraiment qu'il y
ait union socialiste à l'assemblée
nationale et après le sauna et de la
sorte est ce que vous pensez que pour
leur rendez vous du congrès socialiste
au mois de juin
les débats seront vu l'état d'esprit le
contexte un peu minorés un peu étouffé
jeu alors c'est pareil je le pense
autant que je le souhaite parce que il y
avait des jeux santons sentait pointe de
sujets en fait dans le dans ce congrès
l'émotion d'orientation seront arrêté le
11 avril après les élections
départementales donc ça serait quand
même bien en connaître le résultat
il ya deux sujets qui seront
sensible quelle orientation sort du
congrès et faut-il ou non des primaires
si avec le président sortant
sur les primaires je pense que on va
assister à l'enterrement de cette
affaire pour dès lors que le président
sortant est candidat oui j'entends oui
l'hypothèse inverse non mercredi celui
qui desservaient moi je souhaite avait
déjà annoncé je sais rien du tout moi je
souhaite qu'ils le soient reparler
forcément du rendez vous 2010 est pour
lui oui mailhac donc pour les pour les
primaires si le président sortant et
candidat tout le monde derrière soumet
pas aux primaires donc je pense que ça
dans le congrès ça devrait être évacué
pour moi il faut l'évacuer et
deuxièmement il ya l'orientation ça
c'est autre chose il faut que la motion
d'orientation soit pas les petit doigt
sur la couture du pantalon de ce que
fait le gouvernement mais soit en
harmonie avec ce que fait le président
et le gouvernement parce que s'il y
avait une distorsion grave entre
l'orientation du parti socialiste ce que
l'on appelle dans notre jargon la motion
finale
la motion ultime là ce serait non
seulement on aurait dit que je serais
probablement pas que ce soit un congrès
anti hollande il faut aussi que l'on
allait laisser ben oui mais c'est la
motion finale c'est la finale qui compte
pour moi
quelle est la majorité du parti
socialiste oui mais qui ensuite le
dessus jean christophe cambadélis il est
d'accord séduction mais là c'est lui qui
est à la même place prendront les
frondeurs l' aile gauche benoit mais
vous savez vous que vous connaissez nos
règles
du parti socialiste c'est assez simple
vous avez le droit selon les règles de
déposer une motion le 11 avril qui est
soumis au vote le 21 mai c'est ça la
règle
donc n'importe qui peut enfin pas
n'importe qui il y à quelques
obligations respecter peut présenter une
motion
mais voilà elle est soumis au vote de
nos adhérents et ce qui compte c'est le
vote des adhérents et donc j'espère que
ce vote là s'oriente vers là où
l'émotion qui seront en harmonie avec la
politique du président et du
gouvernement et ensuite à une fois qu'on
a fait ça on se retrouve dans notre
congrès et puis il ya les
les accords les alliances etc et il ya
un texte qui sort majoritairement et
c'est celui-là qui doit être en harmonie
avec leur président va il cessa le
congrès socialiste c'est une machinerie
compliqué d'abord nous les socialistes
on est parfois compliqué ça je reconnais
elle est donc vous avez tout un
cheminement vous avez devrait vous
permettre d'être compliqué quand vous
avez le pouvoir
anbar co pas compliqué pour décider mais
on peut être plus subtil pour réfléchir
oui bien sûr et ça commence le 7 février
le 7 février vous avez des contributions
aux téléspectateurs peuvent trouver ça
un peu apprendre à être un peu minorés
par cet état d'esprit nous ont lancé un
appel à l'union socialiste à moi je suis
pour l'union socialiste d'abord et
l'union de la gauche ensuite très simple
j'ai j'ai été élevé même si j'étais
rocardien dans mon parcours
politiquement j'ai été élevé par
françois mitterrand donc l'union des
socialistes elle rassemblement de la
gauche et dans un troisième challenge la
politique la politique le cap économique
et de françois hollande materazzi
aujourd'hui ça non je crois pas parce
que je pense que la politique savez il
ya trois autres pôles il n'y a pas que
je voyais ceci dit flo dire et il n'y a
pas qu'une seule politique non il y en a
d'autres
elle a raison et il ya notamment la
politique y compris à gauche qui
consiste à laisser creuser les déficits
et augmenter la dette non françois
hollande sur ce terrain là pendant sa
campagne on l'a peut-être pas assez
écoutée sur ce sujet a été extrêmement
clair si je suis élue je ne veux pas
creuser les déficits je veux les réduire
c'est très long à faire et je ne veux
pas augmenter la dette même si elles
augmentent quand même je veux je veux
freiner le tout c'est pas de bol la
france 1
son budget vous le changez pas d'un coup
de baguette magique mais le coup de
frein et 50 milliards de dépenses en moi
c'est pas rien vous rappelle que l'ump
dans cette zone dans sa convention du 25
janvier qui est toujours en vigueur
s'en vante pas d'ailleurs ses 130
milliards sur cinq ans 130 sur cinq ans
l'année 2015 est une année de rendez
vous électoraux vous qui êtes qui
prenait le pouls sur le terrain comment
est ce que vous ressentez les choses
justement après ces événements est ce
que le front national peut gagner je
sais pas je dis un chiffre au hasard 10
points de plus où est ce que on peut
s'attendre à ce que peut-être les
l'électorat de gauche qui s'étaient
fortement abstenus lors des dernières
élections se remobilise comment vous
voyez les choses on va avoir un sorte de
premiers tests le 1er février avec
l'élection de la douche dans la
législative là je souhaite vraiment
parce qu'il y avait des craintes étaient
écrits dit par les commentateurs que le
candidat socialiste ne parviendrait pas
forcément au second tour s'était dit un
frédéric barbier
il faut que ce candidat soit aux motos à
jeudi il faut ces électeurs qui vont
décider mais j'espère que ce qui s'est
passé là va avoir un effet y compris sur
cette élection qui est une
une fusion partielle d'une fierté
retrouvée de l'orateur vous avez tout à
fait raison je les récentes y part des
candidats aux cantonales dans mon
département tout simplement qu'elle
finistère quelques parcelles et ces
derniers temps c'était pas forcément
facile d'être candidat socialiste à des
élections et tout d'un coup
pour ceux que j'ai vus avant noël et me
le disait ne sais pas pas évident
d'aller chez les gens ça n'est pas
toujours bien reçus et là par contre
tout d'un coup vous avez une fierté des
candidats fierté leur président fierté
de leur gouvernance et des électeurs qui
compte aussi
ouais d'accord mais admettez quand même
que quand vous êtes en compte par des
bus et que c'est ça ça vous donne une
forte amitié moral évidemment
alors après vous le savez les vois ça se
trient pas ça se compte et donc à partir
du moment là vous voyez bien ce que ce
que ça donne en finale mais vous n'êtes
plus à même de défendre ce que fait
votre président est ce que fait votre
gouvernement et pour la jeunesse que a
légalement will genia les ouvriers les
choses commencent vraiment oui mais la
compagnie ça y est ils sont en campagne
certains avant noël déjà ils sont
content et je pense c'est la même chose
pour les régionales en tout cas bon
c'est vrai que la gauche a beaucoup de
départements alors dirige beaucoup de
conseils généraux
elle dirige presque toutes les conseils
régionaux donc c'est sûr que ça va être
difficilement gagné plus ça je reconnais
est ce que c'est possible d'éviter la
débâcle
oui j'espère même que 20 mois je suis tu
je pense que dans quelles proportions a
je donne jamais de proportions moi je
considère qu' on doit garder tout ce
qu'on a et en gagner plus et je sais que
ce ne sera pas la raclée non dans la
débâcle pas la rater la mode est
catégorique je suis que diggory je
devais vous l'êtes jeux de wii jeu
devrait pas l'être parce qu'il va voulez
vous avoir fait temps d'élection je sais
ça me permet d'être aussi catégorique de
gasquet
évitez la baisse parce que je trouve que
nos candidats et nos électeurs le socle
socialiste je lis entendus dans la ville
qui est la mienne moi même où j'ai perdu
l'élection
je les jeux l'est bien entendu c'est
comme si savoureux a redonné du tonus
vous voulez on a vécu un drame terrible
une barbarie fonds au considérable
d'accords une réaction apprécié juste du
président et l'éxécutif
et puis cette foule qui est venue les
chefs d'état
tout d'un coup le front national selon
vous ne va pas on va voir ça je sais pas
je suis très prudent je sais pas comment
l'électorat va sans doute qui la sonde
électorale lui le front national ce qui
va baisser pas baissé je ne sais pas
mais la france s'est retrouvée le monde
a retrouvé sa france
que voulez vous ça ça booste ça donne du
tonus et même dans le monde économique
un fait on dit souvent l'économie à la
psychologie à la confiance et tout ça et
ça ça la donne moi j'étais moi même
extrêmement fier mais vous êtes monsieur
monsieur parti socialiste à l'elysée non
puisque vous en parlez avec une fougue
la une est ce que j'ai toujours pensé à
je connais moi je suis adhérent du parti
socialiste depuis 40 ans à j'en ai vécu
des hauts des bas etc
mais je sais très bien ta partie qui
datent de 1905 et l'un a vécu des vertes
et des pas mûres
il a fait d'excellentes choses il a eu
des délais moins bonne chose aussi mais
il est un socle permanent dans
l'histoire de la france il restera enfin
je vous interroger sur la façon dont
vous avez vos surveille ça un peu comme
le lait sur le feu à l'elysée
non non non je cherchais des notes à
françois hollande sur le sujet du parti
socialiste au la mer et vous chers est
arrivé parler d'accord je fais tout pas
sur le parti socialiste mais malgré ça
peut arriver là merci merci car ils ne
paieraient pas justement donc perrine
tarneaud va nous rejoindre maintenant
pour vous interroger sur votre rôle
exact auprès de françois hollande
ça c'est toujours un mystère à c'est un
mystère alors c'est la dernière partie
de l'émission va nous éclairer enfin
qu'est-ce que vous faites donc auprès de
françois hollande qui bien sûr comme
tous les présidents de la vème
république est exposée au syndrome du
château alain c'est à dire isolement
sandra cerqueira on l'appelle le
syndrome de la tour d'ivoire ce
sentiment d'isolement qui guette tous
les présidents de la république
comme ses prédécesseurs françois
hollande n'a pu l'éviter
rappelez-vous valéry giscard d'estaing
il essayer justement de recevoir des
gens divers et variés pour avoir contact
avec les français
mais jacques chirac aussi nicolas
sarkozy de même et c'est tous ont tenté
et se sont rendus compte que en réalité
la concentration du pouvoir est telle
qu'ils ne peuvent pas s'échapper de
leurs fonctions le chef de l'état dit ne
pas avoir anticipé cet isolement de
l'avoir même sous-estimé son entourage
assure qu'il en souffre françois
hollande reconnaît aujourd'hui que le
président normal n'existe pas ses amis
politiques disent l'avoir vu avec regret
tomber dans le piège de l'elysée c'est
presque malgré lui que le président
s'est enfermé dans le pouvoir françois
hollande a mis du temps à prendre toute
la dimension de sa fonction et tout ce
que tout ce qui est allé avec le fait
qu'il peut pas avoir le même rapport aux
gens aux français qui ne peut pas
répondre à toutes les questions tout le
temps qu'on lui pose dès qu'on lui tend
un micro à gestion de son
tout un tas de choses qui lui coûte
cette journaliste du monde a passé une
semaine en immersion à l'elysée ce qui
l'a frappé le besoin de liberté de
françois hollande ait envie de
s'échapper plus forte que chez ses
prédécesseurs il en fait il s'autorise
un peu d'aidé échappée hors ordonné
lisez le soir principalement le soir où
il se rend son média et sans publicité
s'est pas inscrit à son agenda
mais il se rend dans des endroits où on
est invité pour essayer de d'aller à la
rencontre de vrais gens entre guillemets
et pour fuir une solitude qui lui pèse
françois hollande s'est entouré d'un
proche collaborateur dont les liens
familiaux le rassure son ami de toujours
jean-pierre jouyet
on appelle ça le syndrome du repli voilà
perrine tarneaud est avec nous
monsieur voyant sa compagne et françois
hollande lors de certaines de ces
soirées que non non non je vous
appartenait aux vrais gens
oui il l'a dit il l'a dit dans une
formule dans le
discours du bourget c'était le 22
janvier ça fait trois ans la semaine
prochaine
j'aime les gens et c'est quelqu'un qui a
besoin de ce lien là avec lille il en a
besoin
c'est à la fois politique et c'est aussi
affectif presque un peu charpenel si
vous n'avez pas besoin de partager ça
avec jacques chirac
oui exactement il jacques chirac et
messins mitterrand était avait une plus
grande distance de giscard il lui il
avait une méthode il invitait les
éboueurs à prendre le petit déjeuner ou
sa vie c'est chez les gens oui oui mais
il n'empêche qu'il éprouvait quand même
ce besoin là général de gaulle au début
de la cinquième
mon âge me permets de lui avoir serré la
main en 1959 il était au mieux il aimait
bien les foules
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ce pouvoir
quand même de l'elysée qui isole il
isole c'est à dire rien moi samedi à
chalon prend d'abord rendez compte le
nom d' obligations d'un président sur
une année je le vois dans la cour de les
effrayer mans le nombre de chefs d'états
de chefs de gouvernement
deux ministres qui viennent dans une
année visites officielles ou visitent le
plus plus plus discrète si je puis dire
le nombre d'obligations cas le président
haut dans les conseils européens dans
les jets machin d'en perdre alors je
n'en perdait pas forcément mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que le vrai contact
vous n'êtes pas tous les jours c'est
vrai sur les marchés vous pouvez pas
faire ça parce que vous êtes le conseil
les rythmes du conseil des médecins
je vois bien est compris dans son agenda
vous avez des rendez vous réguliers avec
certains ministres régaliens c'est
normal donc vous êtes happé par ça et
puis l'ambiance de l'elysée fait vous
êtes pris en charge finalement y compris
pour la sécurité du président la
sécurité du président et elle est un peu
renforcé forcément avec les
donc pris en charge et d'étranges adam
mais tous les présidents y compris sous
la troisième république certains
disaient que c'est une prison c'est
armand fallières disait c'est un bel
endroit mais y'a pas d'avancement elle
est donc vous êtes vous êtes vous êtes
pris quoi dans cette affaire et françois
hollande et ses chopes d'abord il aime
beaucoup sa liberté c'est simple soirée
puis vous à vous aussi
moi si vous voulez mon rôle d'abord je
lui fait traditionnellement des notes
parce que j'aime bien faire ça et je
rends compte des des élus je fais des
déjeuners ou des dîners d'élus je les
fais en arrivant quand il est arrivé
pour des députés élus pour la première
fois pour des sénateurs je les fais pour
des prises dans le conseil généraux je
les fais pour les mères ayant perdu leur
mandat
et dieu sait si j'étais bien placé pour
l'avenir il vous consoler mais voilà
j'en ai reçu pleins 80 environ publique
est elle à partir de là comme je reçois
depuis le mois de décembre et je
continue
compris cette semaine et la semaine
prochaine des associations d'élus de
palets grandin mais les associations
thématiques ou deux qui sont se
réunissent par taille de ville et puis
après je fais un compte rendu au
président voilà qu'est ce qui m'a est
que vous lui adressez directement direct
direct des satisfactions tirez vous
personnellement que cette pré j'aime
faire ça
j'aime la vie politique ah j'aime la vie
politique et quand vous aimez la vie
pour lui mais on a envie de résultat une
influence ça alors ça alors ça vous ne
savez jamais si vous êtes influent ça
vous ne pouvez pas le savoir et surtout
pas auprès de françois hollande qui qui
lui d'autres contacts que vous même
donc vous savez pas quelle est votre
part
il faut d'ailleurs de 801 fois sade mais
vous ne pouvez pas il faut pas le savoir
je lui ai dit un jour le pouvoir suppose
du sacré l influence du mystère donc il
faut rester retrouver alors il a fait à
ses conseillers bien si la chance
d'avoir cet accident
retour avec un petit mot tout ça parce
que pour quelqu'un qui est kate auprès
d'un président d'un môme d'un ministre
c'est la même chose de d'autres
fonctions mais celle-là est suprême
c'est très important de savoir que ce
que vous lui communiquer et quand même
lui donc il faut qu'il y ait un retour
est-ce que c'est facile de garder une
franchise un ton très direct alors
vis-à-vis de d'un du chef de l'état que
vous connaissez depuis 30 ans cet ancien
mari alors il faut il faut vous voilà
quand vous écrivez moi je fais beaucoup
par écrit en réalité un jeu fait
beaucoup un pompier oui parce que c'est
facile hein et puis votre pensée elle
est plus ordonnée quand vous faites un
écrit est ce que ça vous permet d'être
direct date fouet vous pouvez la thur et
vous demande aussi de temps en temps ben
passe donc me voir ont pris ma journée
vient vraiment
non moi alors je demande un rendez vous
je l'obtiens le jour demande pas
beaucoup ces gens-là peine de déranger
un président ça sert à rien mais c'est
votre ami
oui mais ça n'empêche ça empêche ses
résidents est-ce qu'on peut être
conseiller du président la république
est également son ami tient à 1039 jeu
pendant dix ans et jean pierre jouyet
oui par exemple oui oui je pense qu'ils
ont fait en tout cas le système marche
cela vous pouvez attendre pour vous non
mais j'ai en tout cas pour le pour
constater leur décès marché bien aussi
avec pierre rené lemas avant mais il
n'avait pas la même relation historique
que l'ancien secrétaire général de
l'elysée voilà maintenant à laquelle est
avec jean pire juillet je vois ce qu'on
dit cependant que amitiés politiques
c'est instantané
il faut croire qu'il ya des exceptions
de compatibilité est ce que le
conseiller du président le public peut
lui même être évitée parce que forcément
votre fonction suscite un certain nombre
de fantasmes
on se demande un peu quel est votre
pouvoir d'influencé comment jouer ou non
moi je joue pas parce que c'est moi je
suis pas je suis je j'ai 40 ans de vie
politique d'élection de ça dont je suis
pas dans une même position que certains
autres pour beaucoup de conseillers
présidentiels ou ministériel c'est un
moment de leur vie d'un moment leurs
parcours professionnels y compris donc
vous pouvez pas comparer ça moi je ne
demande rien je suis pas membre du
cabinet vous l'avez dit puisque je
n'appartiens pas à l'organigramme
je n'ai pas de contrat de cabinet pas de
rémunération donc je fais ça françois
hollande m'a demandé quand il a été élu
qu'est ce que tu aimerais faire j'ai
simplement est avec toi l'elysée mais
les gentils mais les gens qui viennent
vous voir vos visiteurs s'il faudra
montrer mais ils ont tous quand même des
émissions ils ont éventuellement des
messages à faire passer en effet cette
position leur servait à vous décidez
vous décidez vous même ce que ce que
vous faites c'est une position que vous
avez donc demandé un pas de lien direct
pas de place effectivement dans
l'organigramme vous permet de survivre à
tous les changements cabinet et y en a
eu le temps d'être libre n'aurait de
survivre aux je ne cherche pas à
survivre dans suffit
mais oui il ya des changements mais dans
sa tête des conseillers ouais mais c'est
noland ne soyez pas surpris parce que la
plupart de ceux qui ont changé de
fonction
ils ont pris une autre fonction parce
que c'est dans leur histoire c'est dans
leur parcours et c'est pas surprenant
françois l'on n'a pas un cabinet énorme
hein il en 2012 quand il est arrivé il
avait un cabinet de 40 48 ou 49
personnes je crois que sarkozy avait un
cabinet de 60 ou 70 donc il a beaucoup
réduit la toile et ben dans sept de ces
personnes qui sont là c'est normal qu'à
un moment donné le c'est fatigant si
pour certains moi je sais c'est pas
grave mais pour certains c'est sont ils
sont vraiment sur le fond c'est très dur
pour venir justement au début du
quinquennat françois hollande a mis
longtemps à endosser le costume de
président de la république
pourquoi selon vous vous lis que vous
qu'il connaisseurs il et puis là il
il est enfin moi je suis toujours pensé
qu'il est allé plus vite que ce que l'on
a dit mais l'image qui était la sienne a
été celle que vous venez de traduire
il a fait d'ailleurs une campagne
peut-être aussi l'erreur d'appréciation
sur la présidence normale alors ça
c'était un bon thème de campagne
mais ça vous êtes président c'est une
fois que j'ai président vous vous n'êtes
plus normal ou plutôt vous rester normal
mais votre fonction ne l'est pas et donc
ça m'a beaucoup marqué ça l'est les
français la présidence normale c'était
évidemment par comparaison avec son
prédécesseur
donc il en a beaucoup joué il a fait
même bruit là depuis longtemps quand
même temps qu'à rentrer un peu dans la
laure moi je trouve pas joué non je
trouve qu'il a été assez vite et pour
moi ça a commencé
j'ai envie de dire dès le mois de
septembre 2012 s'il était bien installé
quoi après bon parce que quand il est
élu en mai un prix y est les
législatives il ya les légistes avec bon
un peu de décompression quand même
pendant les bas-fonds lui a reproché de
prendre des vacances
on est content à feu mois au mois d'août
2012 et pour tout le monde a oublié que
sarkozy en avait primé puis il est allé
pique-niqué avec george bush quand même
je moi je préférerais voir rollandin
brégançon que j'ai cliqué george bush a
quand même avec vous savez une part de
travail à 6 oui oui peut-être une part
des scud sur la guerre en irak que nous
avions accepté de faire et
et donc il est allé assez je pense qu'au
mois de septembre il était dedans mais
la population ne le voyait c'est vrai je
peux pas contester
je voyais pas comme ça est ce que vous
vous trouvez qu'il a changé depuis je
pense qu'il est en gravité oui oui des
mots et les plus graves de ces pesant
lalalala et pratique toujours l'humour
oui enfin mon avis m'amuse retient à ce
que je pense qu'il pourra en faire
beaucoup plus et avec mais bon le pays
dans la république ne peut avoir un
point sur lequel beaucoup d'espoir
peut-être ne déçoit pas mais j'ai
toujours aimé les meetings qu'il a fait
pendant la campagne
et quand il était premier secrétaire du
parti social et quand il était candidat
encore elle c'était un bonheur ses
meetings
si j'ai un regret aujourd'hui en fait
c'est que j'aimerais le revoir en
meeting de natation le président ne fait
pas de vous conservez je crois perpignan
toutes les archives écrites tout les
noms alors je les fais je oui alors je
les fais oui je les fais jusqu'en
jusqu'au 15 mai 2012
d'accord tout ce qui avant j'ai récupéré
le plus que j'ai pu que vous allez
transmettre quoi et en plus non après le
15 mai j'ai continué et j'étais si je
peux dire comme ça rappe a rappelé à
l'ordre mardi non depuis le 15 mai 2012
et l'investiture
tout doit aller aux archives d'état dont
ceux que j'avais gardé avant et qui
était à la fondation jean jaurès a fait
en fait il a fallu rendre est-ce que
c'est l'enfer un livre non mononc hijab
ou les finales elles y vont trouver
justement c'est trop à la mort y est
et voilà puisque la toute meilleure les
livres sont à la mode c'est vrai vous
avez évoqué il ya un instant les
vacances à brégançon à l'époque françois
hollande était accompagné de sa compagne
valérie trierweiler l elysée vous a
demandé un peu de montées au créneau
lorsque le livre est sorti un merci pour
ce moment est-ce que vous craignez une
réplique de l'ancienne compagne du
semaine à un tome 2 ou l'adaptation
cinéma non aujourd'hui je crée je
croquais plus rien à craindre ce que
vous le livre jacqueline au moral aussi
oui moi je pense que que rien à craindre
non je pense que c'est klaus s'est clos
pour les français pourquoi pour les
français mais oui l'autre non pas pour
les auteurs c'est leur affaire
je pense que ouais je pense que c'est
derrière nous et derrière lui très bien
merci
mais rapaillés hambourg merci merci
péril on vous remercie encore une fois
c'est la première fois que vous
participez à une émission de 45 minutes
comme cela depuis que vous conseiller
françois hollande votre ami de 30 ans à
l'ena et merci merci merci à vous pour
soir à tout ça très vite